what is going on welcome to the final
tentatively final I suppose flask
tutorial video on our practical flash
tutorial series in this video we're just
going to kind of wrap up everything with
some final things at this point you
really should have everything you need
to make at least this very website now
just in case you're looking for some
code the example code on how something
is done or maybe in the future even you
want some sample code for how something
is done or if you think you can do
something better I do have everything up
on github if you just go to github.com
slash Python programming come here this
not only has all the source codes for
most of the series anyways they're all
here the other thing it has is the
website so let me try and find it let's
just type oh here it is right here so
here's the Python program and on that
website we can click here and here is
everything you need there are some small
changes for example DB connect by is not
filled out you will of course need to
enter in your own database there and
then the email script will also error
because it has nothing in the fields you
would need to fill that one in as well
that one's just in case we get a
donation so uh anyway other than those
two things you should be able to
basically take this entire website just
copy and paste it over and this is the
real Python program net now if you want
to get the code you can of course clone
it however you want but then also you
can submit code if you want to be a part
of helping out on either improving this
or you can also improve any of these
other programs and stuff that we've
written over time feel free to request
invite not too particular on the invites
so you can't really do too much damage
to us anyways it's not really connected
to the true websites so anyway uh if you
want to be a part of that let me know
just ask for an invite and you probably
get one you can also for kit and all
that so back to the website uh the one
thing I really wanted to touch on mainly
in this video
is once you have a website how do you
actually get found so if you look on
Google there's all kinds of people you
know putting forth their SEO tricks and
all this for the most part there are no
tricks there's no shortcuts to getting
your website found before everyone else
backlinks while they work when use right
are often abused and they don't work and
you will eventually be penalized so what
is the main way that people get their
websites found that's Google com it's in
Google coms best interest to get the
best content and give it to their their
you know the people that are searching
their users so it's in Google's best
interest to do this automatically you
don't actually need to cater to Google
very much anymore in the past you you
needed to and you could cater to Google
and you could kind of abuse it to the
point where you would do some tricks and
you could get easily on the first page
and fairly easily the top results
nowadays that's not really the case and
if you do cheat enough you'll actually
be penalized and you'll be hurt so
that's the first thing so so what is the
way to get ranked on Google the way to
get ranked on Google is to have content
ok so content is king Google knows this
and Google is very good my time you put
your website up you can actually um you
can track how many times Google even
comes to your website but you can do
this either through Google Analytics or
you can actually track for what robots
are visiting your website and you'll see
that Google actually crawls your website
a lot and so almost immediately when
your website is up you're going to find
that Google is on your website so
getting Google there just in case Google
isn't visiting your website the best way
to get Google there immediately is to
create a sitemap and you submit that
sitemap - I think it's webmasters
google.com you try that webmaster Google
see what we find
yes Google com slash webmasters so you
saw up there submit your website submit
your sitemap now if you have a wordpress
site sitemaps are easy enough but if
you're doing flask sometimes a sitemap
can be hard so this is the sitemap code
as I just said we have all the code
is available right here github.com slash
Python programming so you can copy this
or you can just head there and copy the
code if you want I'll just kind of
explain it real quick this code actually
grabbed um from somebody somebody put up
the coded changed a couple of things I
can't remember exactly what I believe it
was actually this line here was not
valid but anyway we brought this in this
is basically a taproot sitemap.xml
that's the address you want to your
sitemap when you submit a sitemap to
Google you should tell it actually where
what the link is but other crawling
engines are going to just automatically
search for your website slash sitemap
XML so you'll want to just go ahead and
put it at that URL and so anyway so
you've got this is the app root this
one's going to go ahead and generate
this and basically the way it generates
that is it actually just goes through
your init dot pi file and it's going to
get all the links it's going to get them
by these rules here it's going to add
that to your URL here and it's going to
post that to your sitemap so we can
actually go to our site map did I not
yeah here we go
so it's Python program net slash sitemap
XML and here's a nice XML document of
all the stuff on my website so obviously
as you get a bigger and bigger website
you get the more stuff you have you can
build this sitemap all on your own by
hand if you wanted that's not
recommended but if you wanted you could
so anyway you can use that code makes
you know submit your sitemap you
actually don't have to do anything
though Google doesn't require you to
even tell them hey I have a website
Google will find it okay
as far as backlinks are concerned I
wouldn't really worry too much about
them but of course you know if you for
example I have Python programming net I
try to share that website on places like
Reddit and of course I've got it all
over the place on YouTube here and that
kind of stuff but actually Python
programming net or I already get about
anywhere from 600 to 800 organic visits
a day per day and um
not done anything I've not really I've
got some backlinks and stuff but for the
most part actually not much and the
website isn't even a year old and
actually I just changed from WordPress
now to my own site but either way it's
not a year old and we're already getting
that much organic so for the big guys
that's not very many organic searches
anyways but you can imagine that's
actually a pretty big number of people
that are finding my websites through
organic searches and really the only
thing I've done is submit my site map
the old the biggest thing if you want to
get visitors is to have good content and
generally when you have content you want
to make sure that you know you you have
good language so don't have typos if you
can avoid them this version of this
website probably has a lot of typos
because I don't have any form of
spellcheck and generally pretty good
about typing but I'm sure I've got typos
you want to watch out for that you want
to watch out for confusing language
Google knows what is confusing language
and what's not confusing language so you
want to be careful about that Google
also knows if your website is responsive
or not so that's by response if I mean
you know if we take this website what
can we do with this can we squish it up
you know and just does it go awry turns
out we can switch it up so we can view
this on a phone we can do all kinds of
stuff and it should still work and all
of that so Google knows that Google
knows how long does it take for your
website tour to load right so this
website loads pretty darn fast but if
you have a website that doesn't
necessarily load very fast um generally
anything above like 500 milliseconds
it's a bad thing you're going to want to
figure out how you can get your website
to load fast Google knows that people
like pretty pictures make sure you've
got some pictures from time to time not
too many not too little
Google is slightly impartial to adds a
lot some people think that maybe Google
might rank you higher if you have ads
because it's in their best interest
that's not really true if anything ads
actually hurt your website a little bit
because users don't like ads so you can
think about that pictures content but
the biggest biggest biggest thing is
that you just have good content
probably the biggest ranking into your
website is what do actual users do on
your website
okay so Google knows especially now
since Google's got Google browsers
Google knows well how long I use your
spending on your website what's your
bounce rate ie how many people come to
your website and get out so how many
people are sticking around how long are
they sticking around are they
interacting with your content do they
appear to be enjoying your website that
is what will drive Google to rank your
website a little higher and a little
higher over time and slowly you know get
you up into that but you know first page
and the first result for various things
but it can take a while so you just have
to keep that in mind
there's just no shortcut really but it
can happen really really fast especially
if you're in a niche market if you're in
a really tough market it can take a
while it can take a while to get there
so anyways I just thought I would kind
of cover a few things especially the
site map the site map is pretty
important the other thing you'll want to
always have is a robots.txt so we've got
Python programming dotnet and then we
can go to robots dot txt and we can see
the user agent is basically we're
allowing anyone and then disallow is
what we want to disallow the robots to
visit so we're disallowing the register
page we're disallowing the login page
and we're disallowing donation success
because I didn't want because every time
we visit donation success I get an email
so have fun if you want to spam that but
anyway if you visit it I get an email so
I wanted the robots to stop doing that
because they were visiting it pretty
often and I imagine that now that I've
said this someone's gonna go through and
be like yeah visit and I'll have to like
I don't know a track ip's or something
and get that to go away so anyway thanks
for that guys anyway donation success
has it so I didn't want them to do it
and again robots.txt you know you can't
have it's a little harder to have a
simple like files it so like robots.txt
is a great example it's not really a
text file it's
a pseudo text file no different than our
XML file is not really an XML file we're
just kind of faking it and we're doing
the same thing with robots.txt so
robots.txt here it is this is the live
version the dev version is just disallow
all I didn't want any robots on the dev
site but this would be like the live one
and literally it just returns a string
of text so oh and and the reason why we
do that by the way is the robots
actually they don't see it like this
robots.txt
when the robot visit visits what is a
robot see the robot sees source code so
let's look at the source code this is
what the robot sees okay so uh anyway
that's that I just wanted to cover up
some of those final things again if
there's anything that you feel I've
forgotten or whatever you can always
check it out just by coming to the
github slash Python programming you want
to be a part of it that's fine ask for
an invite all the code is up here you
can update all that but most importantly
if you're interested in website code
it's all right here so for example we
could open up the init dot pi which is
kind of big but here it all is there's
all the code and then for example we can
probably find robots.txt there she is
so there's that so thank you all for
following along on this tutorial I had a
lot of fun making it and I actually kind
of discovered a few things by going over
my code a second time around so it's
kind of nice for me as well I love
Falasca hopefully you guys have found a
lot of enjoyment with flask I love how
open it is so it's been a huge help for
me
to finally be able to use a web
development language that I like I don't
have any interest in PHP try Django I
could do it I just didn't like it but
really fell in love with flask so
hopefully it was useful for you guys and
I hope you guys get as much out of it as
I have so anyways stay tuned for more
tutorials questions comments suggestions
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions until next
time